une nouvelle place contre bondissement
de chose qui va faire des fûts de
dioxine de seveso
cette information exclusive d'antenne 2
confirmerait peut-être la présence des
déchets on passa en général cette
information elle intervient au moment où
le ministre italien de la protection
civile nous apprend que le fameux
document déposé devant notaire à milan
où il est souvent cité d'ailleurs pas
remplies nature luigino et comme
garantissant que les déchets avaient été
déposés dans un endroit répondant aux
normes site de sécurité et bien le
ministre nous appréhendons de plomb et
en faire une simple déclaration de
disponibilité et maintenant dix ans
d'une entreprise ouest allemande est
datée de novembre 80 une époque où la
dioxine était encore en italie
bref depuis le passage à saint quentin
selon l'anc est rarement valurent
qu'elle menait en ce qui concerne la
piste s'arrête un instant qu'à
saint-quentin géré par monsieur par 1 go
on sait qu'ils ont réformé mais depuis
septembre dernier ils ont disparu
bernard par un guide l'homme clé que
l'on voit ici sortir une fois de plus du
camion un juge et qui toujours en pole
mais se refuse à plat du jour ont ils
payé pour se taire c'est une hypothèse
mais il y en a d'autres
la piste devient alors allemande et l'on
cherche d'abord dans une décharge
albanais après de heidelberg labadie
cherix tendre en effet des documents
saisis pour pour cette société avait
pris des contacts avec bernard paraguay
il ya deux ans on était dans la ligne
concept qui centrait au second
mais pour l'instant on n'a rien trouvé
cependant en allemagne de l'est
les écologistes agitent interviennent et
s'intéresse à une autre décharge en
moselle de münchen a gan en instruments
sur les affirmations d'un informateur
anonyme
la justice est saisie et l'on creuse des
recherches se sont interrompues hier
soir faisant reprendre ce matin
et pour l'instant aucune trace de
dioxyde nous avons une troisième piste à
vous proposer toujours en bas ça à côté
de münchen hagen une autre légende du
reggae
en l'état les salles de hoàn gelson
enquête
j'ai retrouvé trois transactions qui
avait eu lieu entre monsieur par un
grand est une société allemande de la
vessie qui exploite une des changes n'a
pas dit de quel seuil en effet dans
cette décharge avant 1980 ont été
entreposés quelques 4000 tonnes de
déchets en provenance de l'usiné de
finlande est maintenant un rond de
poulenc pour par l'intermédiaire de
monsieur paringaux ces mêmes déchets que
monsieur paringaux après envoyé vers la
décharge de roumazières ans sharon par
ailleurs j'ai également accord pour que
des terres imprégné de dioxine avaient
été entreposés dans des décharges de
basse saxe
juste après l'accident de seveso en
attente tous ces éléments permettent
donc de penser que cette piste de
renault gelson ou d'une décharge de
basse saxe est extrêmement sérieuse